I'm Gary Stevenson former trader and people's
economist this is Gary's Economics
today we're going to talk about what the economy
would look like if we fix wealth inequality
okay if you watched my videos so far you could be
forgiven for coming away a little bit depressedright
i made my money by betting that the economy
would be broken forever that is going to get worse
i've explained in my other videos that if we
don't do anything about wealth inequality
it's going to get worse and worse and worse
housing affordability is going to get worse
ordinary people won't be able to afford houses
wages will stagnate and it'll be difficult to get a good job
so i get a lot of *messages* from people saying
look i like your videos but they're making me feel
bad about the future and um i don't
want to do that so i want to explain is
this idea that wealth inequality is killing theeconomy
it makes some bad predictions if we don'tdo
anything about wealth inequality but what italso
does is open up the possibility that if wedo
do something and we do change wealth inequality
we can make this economy work so much better
for ordinary working people and families
now imagine a different possibility... imagine if rather
than the rich owning  all of the wealth in our society
and the rest of us having to pay them to use it
imagine if the wealth was more equally distributed
so we all owned a little bit of the property and also
the corporations and the land this would mean that
instead of ordinary working people paying a big
chunk of their salaries to the rich every month
we will be paying those salaries to each other
and we'd also be receiving it from each other
this would mean we would all have a passive income
every month that we could use to fund our lives
but not only that if the money instead of going
to the super rich is going to ordinary people
well we know that ordinary people spend the money
that they get as opposed to the rich who save it
that means that instead of the money
going up to the rich to buy our houses
it will go between ordinary people who will
then spend it again to drive each other's wages
instead of that negative spiral of ordinary people
getting poorer and house prices going up
you'd have a positive spiral of money going in between
ordinary people driving wages up every time it goes around
now that may sound unrealistic
but it's happened before
in the 20 years after the second world war in the 50s&60s
when we had much higher taxes on the very rich
housing was much much more affordable for ordinary people
you could buy a house for two to three times average income
that was 50 years ago before the internet
if we were to have a much more equal distribution now
housing could be so much more affordable
wages could be so much higher
and we could have so many more options
in how we live our lives
most importantly security would be much more
affordable for ordinary people and families
100 years ago there was an economist
called John Maynard Keynes
he's one of my favorite historical economists
British of course like all the best economists
and he said about 100 years ago that he expected his
grandchildren would only work for 15 hours a week
obviously you'll see now that if you try and
work for 15 hours a week you're probably going
to struggle to feed your family so why was Keynes
wrong? Keynes' idea was over the next 100 years
technology would improve massively that would
mean that we could produce the same amount of
goods and services with much much less work he
thought that would mean that wages would go up
and up and up and ordinary people could afford
to work less and less and live better lives
why hasn't that happened well some economists will
tell you the reason that has happened is because
people simply want more stuff so they can't work
15 hours a week because they want more stuff
i mean those economists like most economists
probably come from rich families because
if you don't come from a rich family and
you try working for 15 hours a week
you'll probably realize you ain't
going to get much stuff at all for that
so we can understand why Keynes was wrong if we
understand the cases in which Keynes was right
because there are some people in this society
who don't even have to work 15 hour weeks
if you watch my last video 'what is wealth?' you will
have seen that Jeff Bezos even if he doesn't work at all
will make $6billion a year and verywealthy
families that have wealth of say £50million
they don't have to work at all andthey
can make £1-2million incomeevery year
so what we have created is a societywhere 95%
of us have to work long hoursjust to get by
4.9% of us don't have to work andcan still live
and 0.1% of usget millions of pounds a year
even if they don't get out of bed so Keynes was right
we could alllive working 15 hours a week
but instead we've chosen to give all the money
to this small group of super wealthy families
while the rest of us
have to fight to get them to pay our salaries
so look that is the key message here right
if you have a very wealth unequal society
even if you have great technology all of that
technology as well as all of the land on the property
is going to be owned by the super rich
the super rich don't like to spend a lot of money
so we all need jobs but all the wealth
is owned by super rich people
who have machines to do the work for them
and we need to convince them to spend money on us
if that's what we do then it is inevitable
wages will be low and housing will be unaffordable
but the key message is
it does not have to be that way
when i talk about reducing wealth inequality
it's not just about making society fairer
it's about making the economy work for
ordinary people if we were to do that
wages could be massively higher
houses could be massively more affordable
and we could live Keynes' dream
of being able to work 15 hours a week
but it doesn't just have to be working 15 hours a week
it would massively increase the options
available to ordinary families you know
maybe you do want to work a 100 hour week
but if you work a 100 hour week you'll be able to
get rich and you'll be able to live a life of luxury
and if you want to work fewer hours
you can spend more time with your family more
time with your kids you could spend more time
pursuing your hobbies you could spend more time
making videos about wealth inequality on youtube
these would be options available to ordinary people
rather than simply working
all the hours of the day
just to take care of your family
Look, my overarching message here is
things dont have to be this way
if we don't do anything things are
going to get worse wages will fall
houses will become more unaffordable
our kids lives will be worse than our lives
ordinary people's finances will be insecure
we will live lives where we don't know whether our
kids will be able to have financial security or not
but if we do something about wealth inequality
it's not simply about making this world fairer
it could massively transform the economy
and the lives of our kids
it could give them the freedom to pursue their passions
the freedom to make money the freedom to become rich
the freedom to have nice houses
the freedom to have secure families
This is the potential future we could have
if we fix wealth inequality
so when i make my videos
and i make my pessimistic predictions
that is what will happen only if we don't do anything
but if we do something if we fix wealth inequality
that future of wealth and security for everyone
could be there for us
but it's only going to happen if we make it happen
and if you want to help me do that
make sure to watch the next video
'how we're going to make the economy change'
at the moment these guys are profiting from a crisis that's
going to keep our economy in a slump for 50 years
there is one other thing they can do
with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mum's house